The joe rogan experience.
People steal everything.
Yeah.
This is Duncan Trussell.
Yeah,
I saw that on fucking unbelievable.
Joey's on the far right.
That's insane that we were so cute.
I got the sexy lucky seven.
Can you get it?
So just as whole body feels,
the chrome was 44 I was 44 was my uncle.
Lucky seven cause like that.
Wow.
That's so crazy.
Look at you dude.
So how old are you in this picture?
1414 God damn Joe.
You cute.
You're cute as a button.
Look at David Ruiz.
Turn around and talking to the microphones.
Can hear this too.
That kid right there on this screen to that kid with the Afro was a very
interesting story.
This guy right here because we will,
we were horrible basketball team at Mckinley.
Can you go full screen?
Moved in covers on the neighborhood.
Does it do the,
he could jump.
He was five foot eight but this kid could fucking chump like Julia survey.
So he was Dominican.
His name was Louis Hernandez.
I'm from Jersey just playing that.
They just cut it short and called him Louie the Nigga.
They said,
fuck it,
we don't care if he's Dominican.
We're not gonna even think about that.
We're just going,
this is David rule as they called him that to his face too,
like Louise and did he get pissed?
Fuck you bitch.
And he was a tough kid.
He got manager when you can tell it was like he,
I think he bit slap two or three people that the best thing he did was we used
to do acid.
When we first started smoking weed in the eighth grade,
we go behind the soccer field and north Bergen and he let us blow smoke into his
afro and see the smoke come out of you.
How cool.
This was the crew.
So I know your mother fuckers scroll down to the,
all right.
This kid,
he that,
no,
that kid dad was David Black.
We graduated together and I knew him after the fact that one night he came into
Jo married,
it's like dog,
you gotta call you gotta give me a ride.
If he give me a ride,
I'll give you a rock guy.
We gave him a ride.
He gets out of the corner of Western Yoga.
My three minutes later he comes running back bleeding with his hair pulled and I
go,
what happened was I went to rob my sister.
I mean he was serious.
He had coke rocks,
but everybody,
I stunk of his fucking hat.
She caught him on the way out as he was pulling out of the window and she just
took,
he was bleeding.
He rob is his sister
is 83 dog at three in the morning.
You asked me for a ride.
I got to do what I gotta do you know how crazy.
That's fucking crazy show.
I wish you could do your own.
Stand by me.
My fucking God.
This is who is this?
Why is this headset small?
When I got this picture,
which one?
The Filipino kit.
Now this kind of left
a zillion and now his family owns a tow truck company in northern New Jersey and
New York City.
If you get told his family is the one that owns it,
I swear to God.
This is fucking crazy shit,
I believe.
Yeah,
it's fucking crazy,
man.
Somebody sent me this yesterday while I was eating dinner and I almost had a
fucking heart attack of friends and goes out.
What I found looking through yearbooks and that's what I was noticing.
I was smoking dope then I was no innocent.
Then I was smoking dope.
I was finger bang and people,
you could still be innocent and finger back.
Me and my mom at the house.
Yeah.
I was okay.
I wasn't crazy.
Then I smoked my first refer when I was 15.
I banked it from my dad and uh,
I had no idea how strong it was and we rolled a joint and me and my friend Josh
and this girl that I was dating,
we smoke this shit and we smoked way too much for 15 year olds,
whatever we were.
And we wound up waking up in various parts of the house,
like blank,
like blink.
It's never happened to me before,
but like blank.
All of a sudden I'd be on the couch,
blink.
All of a sudden I'd be in front of the frigerator like blink all the time in
between the blanks missing.
Wow.
Just arriving places like waking up in a bedroom with short term memory,
not just no short term memory.
It's like my tape gets cut like the,
the,
the events between those two did not exist.
I get so high,
I had zero memory so I would,
what I would think it was,
it was,
I got so high that I would say,
you know what,
I need to just get into the kitchen and maybe get something to eat and maybe
it'll calm this down so my brain's spools up that it's got to figure out to
remember to get to the kitchen to eat.
Cause I'm that high.
And then in between,
during the walking,
I forget everything.
So then boom,
all of a sudden I wake up and I'm in front of the fridge or I go,
what the fuck?
And she was doing it to my girlfriend at the time and my friend was doing it.
My friend Josh was doing it too.
We were all fucking,
it was,
it scared me off of weed for a long time.
Scared me off of weed for a long time.
I didn't smoke weed again for several years after that.
The first time the hydro brother don't get that design.
It's the second or third time and then you like you're outside.
You really start to understand it.
You ended up at a bowling alley by the chocolate milk.
That's why I went and ate.
We had French fries and chocolate milk.
Have you ever had that happen where you felt like you woke up and replaces the
third?
I remember the first two or three years I just smoked,
you know like don't get,
what are you doing on Friday night?
Nothing.
My Mom's leaving.
Perfect.
I'm going to call Joe.
Welcome over some weed on it all,
bro.
My brother found that last time he was going to rat me out.
Oh,
I fucking with smoking me guard and we'll go in and listen to pink Floyd the
wall.
I mean that's not even though the wall wasn't even out yet.
We listen to the Beatles,
sergeant pepper,
but that's it.
Like we get together and rolled a joint.
In those days.
I used to have a glass.
You went to East West,
his head shop and there was a tube and the head was like a flute with this open,
but it had a hole and you're putting a joint in it and you put your finger at
the end.
Joe Light it and you'd like to join and I stuck it in and I'd hold it back.
Then it was like that's,
that was your carburetor when you smoked one of those you got,
sorry.
That's it.
And then we'd sit around and we'd all have money,
you know,
like what do you want to do?
How much you got Donald?
A quarter.
What do you got?
Three daughters.
I got full.
Let's go to the mix.
And you walk to the pizza place member.
You know what?
You just talked.
Stupidity.
You look at each other.
Do I look,
I know you think nick will say I'm high now.
He's on on my,
I come on by the guy and I know bill [inaudible].
It was a fucking,
it was tremendous.
They know how to get in the house and walked past your mother.
Yes.
And that was the night your mother decided to make cookies so that you had to
look and talk to her,
whatever.
That's why you smoke pot dog,
because it brought something different to you.
Life has 13 it made you feel fucking alive.
[inaudible]
you're a fucking human being.